Souths set cuz everyday we just wake up
barely shower bentley brush our teeth
rub our balls make some scrambled eggs
fry [ __ ] kiss send them off [ __ ]
school so they gotta live like that we
live Chef Boyardee
[ __ ] boy RG today we cook it a bit
nummies dish called what was it come
October which is basically you have a
skillet in front of you and you melt
some butter and you cook your meat on it
back of the day when I was slagging my
dick around [ __ ] now try to get [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'll make them tip
bartenbach to the ladies and they'd be
like holy [ __ ] Chef Boyardee signing out
[ __ ]
it's a nutritious booth [ __ ] series for
now I wanted to follow the shrimp cut
the shrimp and the cuttlefish cuttlefish
is just like a bigger version of squid
simply to find squid make sure you
sanitize your hands kids because we all
know you scratch your ass on a regular
basis nobody likes Dookie flakes and
they're spring rolls so hold this super
tight and just shake them for how long
Halle Halle coming along you can cue and
Rihanna a champ for you but in a what oh
my god it sounds like you hurt freaking
lion dancing no [ __ ] dude all of them
thank cuz I used to cook back in my
heyday curse wanted to open up a
restaurant car coming eat [ __ ] suck my
dick
yo what we having for lunch whatever the
[ __ ] I say Youngblood um can I get this
substitute you get substitute it with a
bullet in your mouth [ __ ] my favorite
things easy for McDonald's is their
breakfast [ __ ] then you guys know like
McDonald's does 20% of breakfast now
spots or me you [ __ ] I saw the
other people that you sponsored you
don't even know I'll give you free promo
that's probably why you don't sponsor me
they do for free but a pop Papa please
bother me but uh Papa please sponsor me
I don't know the comics a minute oh look
that cute girl is she single she take it
all right
she's got a boyfriend [ __ ] that's why I
even met him yet but I'm blocking for
him I got you dude I'll back people up
even if I don't know them that's how
gangsta I am I'll break the fight
everybody that's more serious about your
boy his name Matt that's right Matt I
got Joe bad people trying to hit on no
girl for this though
welcome back to another episode of Chef
Boyardee
as you can see real quick we got some
scrimps scrimps aka the thing that gets
you a nice wet [ __ ] later who tryin to
[ __ ] a [ __ ] inside right here cuz you
see this right here this area cuz it's
gonna be a vein but it's not really a
vein
it's an intestinal sac relish it is aka
the story of my life shrimp is fantastic
to the defang mushroom cuz they got
Dookie on the inside and you'll rip that
[ __ ] out like oh yeah give me some
shrimp baby because I know it's [ __ ]
day is not me auntie every time you
homie this is the last time every time
you kiss me kiss me like a nice to meet
you
i layer it to make sure them variation
like distributed evenly most families
actually don't marinate it at all they
just take the meat throw it on the grill
and cook it in the butter but we grew up
my mom Mary he'll come butters left like
dicks sing a song about cucumbers sauce
is what makes a break dish in a lot of
different meals who would have faced off
with it and each dish has a different
flavor of the fish sauce and it's just a
ratio between fish sauce lime juice
sugar garlic and pepper and it just
depends on what you're eating if you're
using fish you want a little bit more
spicy a little bit more garlic if you're
eating spring rolls you want a little
bit lighter a little bit sweeter fish
sauce to me it's the Asian version of
the sauce it just flavors everything
with that extra depth of flavor I mean I
know some of you have smelled that [ __ ]
and Spell smells like somebody just woke
up and spit in your [ __ ] mouth but
tech stuff is delicious welcome to
another episode of Chef Boyardee well we
got to make sure our lettuces and also
our bustles are nice and fresh and clean
because if you eat dirt in your food
that's been on some cow icky you can get
something called salmonella
so the reason why we do it like this
instead of throwing it all in there and
rinsing water on top of it it's so that
like just dirt and stuff will fall down
to the bottom and then you go scoop by
scoop Oh what's there well give me my
big hands wash these damn everybody
talking [ __ ] about 80 people say we
dirtiest [ __ ] well we're not the ones
where shoes in the house
if we clean up vegetables lice and clean
just like this and just to let you know
we were through the one in Europe where
our wigs and [ __ ] because y'all stink
and your greasy making perfume cuz you
never took a bath as you people did take
it back cuz you got some cookin on your
chin hmm Genco Hazen boy wasteful not
like a father and mother who never waste
anything mommy and daddy used to eat but
a kneecap for dinner because we couldn't
afford the good stuff Oh
sound like a rapist this is what you use
to make a spring roll which it's the
wraparound outside whoo that looks what
is that like I have to touch people so
to make it into a rice cracker put on
the fire and then traditionally you
would just kind of put it over the fire
say see how it starts to do that but
with technology
microwave now really maybe super and
thoroughly impressed by you and then it
just went away in tomato two seconds
yeah she was like well this is how we
traditionally do it but [ __ ] it
she got me super interested can she just
top it at the Michael well ah it's hot
Oh aren't you lucky you need to have
this every day yes it is every day
the basis of a spring rule has some
vegetables in there some kind of protein
which is meat obviously we have and
noodles and then you just go a little
kind of like a burrito sees if the rice
paper in first you let it get soft which
just takes it easy
dip it in like kind of warm water plus
you get the brown rice noodle lets you
get this thing I don't know what it's
called Danny you'll get the letters that
mean you'll get some of this one oh the
microwave cracker that then cheated on
little cheater Lin scream musk room are
we gonna lift this off the plate a bit
I'm gonna take the scrunch it towards me
[ __ ] [ __ ]
why don't you ever listen perfect just
don't look at this side the house
hunters are so good look at hers look at
that
it only took me five tries and now on
the fifth one it's restaurant ready I
put a little shrimp at the tip of the
penis so you surf and turf is no joke I
mean this is the best primo I'd ever
have would be the green sea fest let is
a [ __ ] you're a lucky [ __ ] man eating
this every day the secret sauce that
nobody is a lot to know what the recipe
is because her mom had to flee from
Vietnam because everybody wanted this
sauce so bad but that's how secret it is
live mommy had to leave with them
because they want to pick recipes
cuttlefish there's one of the most
dangerous [ __ ] animals in the ocean
cuz they stay packed and what I mean by
that is not when they in the ocean is
when you put this on the grill they pop
off and they splatter even oil just a
few
to go [ __ ] hurt wow I can see what you
mean by when it pops [ __ ] cuddle
[ __ ] oh what's up cuz
you'll pop back in because use your box
dip it hmm then pop the wet side it's
like a crippled [ __ ] you know when
you gangbang as long as me sometimes you
get osteoporosis butter beat is so good
Korean BBQ especially because when you
guys go out to eat Korean barbeque
contrary to popular belief every Korea
does not have that in their home we
actually have one of these like electric
skillet or those portable butane gas
stoves and then we cook it on a nonstick
surface so it's very reminiscent of that
but just a spring roll version when
you're not eating with rice and like
fermented like Korean dishes you have
fresh vegetables the spring roll wrapper
they're marinated beef and whatever
protein and vegetable that you want to
put in and when the butter hits the
skillet with the remaining marinade that
was cooking with the beef it tastes
super good and actually flavors the
vegetables as well so in case the second
or third batch tastes better than the
first one
delicious if you guys want to do this at
home you can't because Lin's mom has a
secret recipe that she fled from him mom
the doctor in I met you I almost missed
you
as you stood right next to me in the are
between detergents around just in front
of Easter me